j'ai je vais vous surprendre dans le bon
sens
elle
est malade
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
n'a jamais caché ses nombreux excès et
ne manquait plus que Madonna découvre
Tik Tok pour multiplier les provocations
live avec la Tic-Toc et au bout de
quelques minutes face caméra elle s'est
carrément mis à inhaler un flacon de
poppers c'est un drogue qui évidemment
dangereuse pour la santé même la
créatrice du contenu ne revenait pas
mais c'était pas enrhumé voilà
c'est une drogue qu'on inale qui fait
tourner la tête
à la base c'est aussi fait pour des des
plaisirs charnels
c'est un excitant sexuel dilatateur
d'animaux
qu'on prenne bien donc la fameuse série
de Jul reprend tout de suite qu'est-ce
que tu viens de prendre du poppers et
elle répond à la vie de la couverture
avec un fou rire parce que visiblement
ça crée aussi des des fous rires
[Musique]
voilà la dernière fois j'ai voulu faire
une petite vidéo un peu drôle je crois
avoir compris que j'avais été mal perçue
j'avais fait un peu la folle dans ma vie
qui est là vous voyez je suis au même
endroit donc tout va bien vous inquiétez
pas il y a pas d'appel à l'aide et tout
va bien pour moi j'ai de très beaux
projets je vais vous surprendre dans le
bon sens donc deux métiers que vous
m'avez encore jamais vu c'est quoi ces
projets
peut-être une dizaine de fois sur les
deux dernières années à chaque fois elle
m'a parlé d'un nouveau projet et à
chaque fois ce projet n'est pas arrivé
là elle veut planche sur un biopic qui
passe en téléfilm sur sa vie à elle et
elle aimerait jouer son propre rôle
non mais quelqu'un d'autre le joue et
qu'elle s'investisse dans un projet qui
peut un peu lui faire sortir la tête de
l'eau et la mettre dans le dans le
milieu entre guillemets du travail et
être entouré par exemple comme quelqu'un
comme Alexa la rocheber par exemple qui
devrait visiblement l'épauler là-dessus
elle aimerait ça et elle aimerait aussi
beaucoup et ça je sais pas c'est
faisable mais elle aimerait beaucoup
faire partie de la bande de TPMP avec
Cyril qu'elle adore énormément on
adorerait c'est pas la mettre à la télé
extraordinaire c'est qu'on est là à
parler d'elle presque chaque semaine et
en fait il y a personne qui fait rien
mais moi j'ai pas votre position
on fait tout et au final on est juste là
regardez la polémiquer sans rien faire
on m'a dit tu aurais eu une aventure
mais alors on a on a échappé au
paparazzi parce qu'ils étaient tout le
temps en bas de l'immeuble donc c'est
vrai donc en bas de chez moi et et il
venait je disais tu gardes ton casque tu
restes sur ta moto je te donne le bip du
garage
mais combien de temps
combien de temps c'était un cheval sur
2007 et 2008 donc 6 ans après la Star
Academy
c'était bien combien de temps ça a duré
quatre mois
il y a aucune histoire d'amour il y a
pas d'engueulade il y a pas d'accès de
cassée des tout la vérité là il y a pas
eu des petits drags des franchement pas
du tout en fait déjà à moitié des
personnes sont en couple en fait c'est
hyper
impressionnant parce que il y a toujours
ce côté hyper bienveillant les uns des
autres on est toujours là à centrer etc
et c'est on est hyper soudé on se
connaît pas tous
les castelier
ma place genre les gens comment ils nous
parlent comme si en fait finalement ils
nous connaissait parce que je pense que
on était tous les soirs avec eux dans
leur salon et en même temps c'est un
impressionnant genre tout l'amour qu'on
reçoit des gens et on n'est pas
forcément préparé à ça parce que les
protège ta copine parce que sur
Instagram fais voir des trucs non
franchement ça va franchement ça va
pour le coup par exemple ma copine a
fait passer aussi de l'aventure au moins
j'ai regardé quelques trucs non mais les
minutes d'appel qu'on aille avec nous
c'était des
voilà pour toi qui va gagner franchement
j'ai pas d'avis parce que c'est les
c'est l'évolution je ne sais pas il faut
que je regarde
ton tour
mérite au travail etc je dirais Enola et
toi alors moi je dirais que celle que je
vais régler la Star Academy je pense
c'est unisha mais si je devais dire
plutôt la personne que j'aimerais vous
gagner je pense ça serait plus un de mes
rêves ça serait genre Chris parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a énormément
touché dans le truc et hier il y a
public qui a fait un article disant que
les élèves avaient peut-être le melon
que ça se ressentait notamment dans les
commentaires sur Twitter etc on pas
l'humour forcément des élèves léa est
très gentil c'est juste que elle a ce
personnage humoristique de dire je suis
si et peut-être que ça vous écoute
pour la première fois la Québécoise fera
ses débuts au cinéma dans une comédie
romantique intitulée love me again et
dans laquelle Céline jouera son propos
rôle elle a également annoncé qu'elle
dévoilera de nouvelles chansons pour ce
film produit par Sony de bonne augure
pour une reprise de sa carrière et
peut-être de la scène c'est née durant
aux côtés de prime qui enca Chopra
Priyanka
mais en plus de sortir de la nouvelle
musique pour la comédie musicale love
again alors raconte-nous parce que je
vois info Déborah c'est quoi ce film en
fait c'est un film qui a adapté d'un
film allemand qui s'appelle SMS von
purch c'est maintenant et bon je crois
et en gros c'est quelqu'un c'est une
femme que c'est une femme qui a perdu
son mari et qui un jour envoie un texto
l'ancien numéro de son de son compagnon
qui est décédé et c'est un autre homme
qui a ce numéro qui vit dans la même
ville qu'elle il tombe amoureux
ils sont fans de Céline Dion et ses
lignes incarnent son propre rôle
d'accord en plus on leur a chance de
voir la superstar sur grand écran et
découvriront par la même occasion un
nouveau morceau à interprété par la
chanteuse c'est ça bande originale c'est
la bande originale